استعاد مسلم كمبوديا جزءا من تراثهم في
مهنه صيد الاسماك
وكثير منهم لا يحسن حرفه غير هذه التي
ورثوها عن اجدادهم لكن راقيه التي فقدت
معظم افراد اسرتها في سبعينيات القرن
الماضي لا تتحمل نبش الماضي
بينما تحمل كل واحده من هؤلاء قصه اليمه
من عهد الخمير الحمر
وابي
وامي ونجوت انا واختي الصغيره فقط لقد
قتلوهم واحدا تلو الاخر دون سبب
يسمن كثير من مسلم كمبوديا سياسه عدم
التمييز بسبب الدين والعرق التي يقولون ان
رئيس الوزراء هونسين تبناها منذ وصوله الى
السلطه قبل 38 عاما
وفي حفل افطار رمضاني ضم ممثلين عن مختلف
شرائح المجتمع الكمبودي اعتبر تكريما
للاقليه المسلمه تعهد هونسين بتعزيز روح
التسامح من خلال دمج كامل للاقليات في
اجهزه الدوله
نحن ملتزمون بتعزيز حريه الدين والمعتقد
والانسجام بين معتنقي مختلف الاديان بما
يدعم السلم المجتمعي هو عامل مهم للغايه
من اجل التنميه الوطنيه والتقدم الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي شهد التعليم الاقليه المسلمه
في الاونه الاخيره نقله نوعيه بحسب ما
يؤكده قادتها وذلك بدمج مدرسي الاقليه ضمن
موظفي الدوله وتخصيص حصص لابناء المسلمين
في الجامعات المحليه والبعثات الخارجيه
يضاف ذلك الى تمكين المسلمين من المشاركه
السياسيه
هدف الحكومه هو عدم التمييز بين المسلمين
وغيرهم سواء في الوظائف او المناصب في
مختلف القطاعات فمثلا لدينا الان عضوان في
مجلس الشيوخ وثمانيه اعضاء في البرلمان
منهم امراتان و15 نائب وزير منهم امراتان
هذا مسجد استركال بالعاصمه
شيد بعد الاستقلال مباشره
حوله الخمير الحمر الى حظيره واستعمل في
فترات ثقنه عسكريه
اصبح اليوم متنفسا لجميع ابناء الاقليه
المسلمه ومزارا سياحيه وهو احد المعالم
الشاهده على الاثر الاسلامي في البلاد
عاش مسلم كمبوديا ما عاشته باقي فئات
المجتمع من تطورات سياسيه تاريخيه واليوم
تتعامل معهم سلطات البلاد كمواطنين وترى
ان امامهم كاقليه فرصه للنهوض بالاستفاده
من اجواء التسامح الديني والعرقي السائده
سامر علاوي الجزيره كمبوديا